[موسيقى]
انا عاده البوتي بكونوا متنوعين خاصه
بالموسيقى يعني الموسيقى عاده دائما بتكون
مخلوط يعني خليط من من الرومانس ومن
الشعبي ومن الكلاسيك مثل ما عودت الناس
انه كل سنه يكون
بس متنوع واكيد بين اللبناني والمصري
والخليجي اولا انا كثير مبسوطه بوجودي هون
مع انه ه اول مره بس دفنت ما راح تكون اخر
مره حاسه ان كير حلو ضخم كثير وانان عاده
اجمالا بحب هالنوع من الرياضه لانه بحسها
انيقه بحسها انيقه يعني بتخلط بين الرياضه
وجمال الاحصنه وخاصه انه هالمنطقه بالذات
دبي بالذات يعني بتتميز بهال التراث هذا
الشيء بيرجع لطبع الانسان انا بطبعي من
اول ما بلشت او من اول ما خلقت اذا بدك
بحب كثير انه اشوف شغلي بحب كثير اطلع على
على شغلي على اعمالي على الاشيا اللي بدي
قدمها على خطواتي ولا مره اطلعت انه اعمل
مشاكل مع حدا ولا ارد على حدا اوقات بسمع
بس بحس انه الرد دائما باعمال ناجحه و
باعمال
فنيه يعني لهم هيك بياخذوا بصمه عند الناس
بحس انه انه ه هذا هو اللي انا لازم اقدمه
للناس وهذا هو اللي لازم اعمله يعني انا
شهات مجروحه بالمراه العربيه لانه انا
امراه عربيه اولا بعتبر ما فيني اعطي رايي
بعتبر انه انه الامراه العربيه خاصه مميز
كير وعم تتميز اكثر يعني عم تقدر توصل شوي
شوي لمناصب كثير كبيره ومناصب كثير عاليه
والمراه برايي هي اهم من الرجل معلش يسمحو
لنا لانه المراه عندها كثير
مسؤوليات عندها الى جانب انه تكون اكيد
امراه ناجحه بالمجتمع وعندها مناصب كمان
عندها عائلتها يعني عند الشق الثاني اللي
هو كمان لازم يكون
فيت مثل ما بقولون شحب اثنين
ف المسؤوليه عليها اصعب واكبر انه ابقى
باللي انا فيه هلا انا صراحه كثير راضيه
علىي انا وصلت له بتمنى الاستمراريه لانه
دائما الاستمراريه هي اهم من النجاح بحد
ذاته انك تحافظي على على هالنجاح اللي انت
وصلتي له وبالنسبه لي محبه الناس هي نعمه
من عند الله وانا على طول بسعى كرمالها ما
في ش انه نحن نحن بمرحله صعبه العالم
العربي بمرحله صعبه كل يلي بقوله وكل يلي
بتمناه انه
نشوف نشوف السلام ونشوف الاتفاق نشوف ايد
وحده لانه اذا ما كنا كلنا نحن العرب ا
اذا ما كنا ايد وحده بيقدروا كثير يزح
حونا بس اذا كنا ايد وحده بنص وان شاء
الله بعم السلام العالم العربي كله هذا
الشي اللي بتمنيه يمكن انا وكل وكل العرب
من
قلبنا